[Music]
[Applause]
around the world forever England have
played cricket Billy Cooper has provided
the soundtrack but after 16 years of
belting out the hits for the barmy army
the time has come to focus on family me
disappearing halfway around the world
for months on end is not like deal from
that scenario so and all good things
comes after comes within so it seems
like the right time Billy's first year
with England couldn't have gone any
better they won an enthralling Ashes
series in 2005 there were loath to
including a 5 nil ashes drubbing two
years later in Australia but he leaves
with memories that will last a lifetime
my disposition we have a very heavy
heart yeah there's a lot of media didn't
it doesn't want to go but and I didn't
want to be that like hanging on too long
I don't want to be you know in my
mid-50s and I think people saying I
should have gone years ago so it just
seems like the right time but yeah it's
gonna be it's been quite emotional so
far I'm sure the last day will be a very
emotional time to be former England
captain sir alistair cooke praise billy
support saying it really has made a
difference it's gonna be a sad day you
know his infamous and famous at certain
times tunes that they're seeing you know
the mutual Johnson's song that you know
when he when he got the one on the
trumpet and that started up and
obviously Jerusalem in the morning you
know led by the trumpet so you know I'm
sure the bomb y'all might have some
replaceable some something up their
sleeve to a place and be he's going to
take some replacing saw the barmy army
now has a vacancy for a trumpeter Billy
says it's the best job in the world and
you get to meet your heroes in amazing
places
but after 52 tests abroad he's out and a
Brady Sky News